all right hi there have a look at these
faces right here so you're probably used
by now to seeing computer-generated
faces of really high quality but
probably you're used to seeing these
faces coming from a generative
adversarial Network however these faces
right here are from a variational auto
encoder now variational autoencoders are
fundamentally different than Ganz and
traditionally they've been a bit harder
to scale up to high resolution images
and give sort of very detailed sharp
output this paper right here attempts to
build such a v AE
for these high-resolution large data set
and like basically details everything
you need to do to get a v AE like this
so the paper is called env AE or I don't
know how to pronounce that a deep
hierarchical variational auto encoder by
Arashi dot and young coats of Nvidia as
I said on a high level this paper is
about how to build a deep hierarchical
variational auto encoder which is sort
of a combination of already existing
techniques combined in a clever way and
then listing all the engineering efforts
that you need to do to actually make
this work and there is not one thing
where you can say AHA this is the thing
that really made it work but each of
these techniques is going to stack and
stack and stack until they reach a model
that surpasses the state of the art on
these data sets and they are also able
to apply this to an entirely new high
quality image data set so these again
are some of these samples from that
model and as you can see they look very
very crisp very sharp and also very
let's say real yeah so really briefly
variational auto-encoders so this paper
to attempts to build a variational auto
code what is it for that you need to
start with a what an auto encoder is so
an auto encoder traditionally let's say
you have an image data set and you take
an image and you train a model that
consists of an encoder
Maps your image to a lower dimensional
space a compressed space which you call
the latent space Z and then you train a
decoder to again go from the latent
space back to the image space and then
you train those two models such that the
distance between the output and the
input is minimized okay this is called
the reconstruction loss and you train
the encoder and the decoder to minimize
that reconstruction loss and they're
about you hope that this latent space
will learn something about the data
lesson now a sort of advanced version of
this and a probabilistic version of this
is the variational auto encoder where we
say what we want to do is we don't want
the encoder to just output the directly
the latent code but we interpret this in
a probabilistic fashion so the encoder
is now a probabilistic function that
outputs a distribution over latent codes
so we take our same image and what we
want to do is we want a Bayesian
basically it's a Bayesian way of
thinking of it we want a distribution
over latent codes corresponding to that
image so our encoder here is not going
to output Z but it's going to output mu
and Sigma so it would be ideal if it
could output an entire distribution but
we're going to make some assumptions
here that that is a normal distribution
and it's going to output the mean and
the standard deviation of that normal
distribution and then you actually in
because now you gotta feed this into the
decoder if you just feed mu you are back
to the normal auto encoder so that
doesn't work what you do is you actually
instantiate that normal distribution
with mu and the Sigma so you plug that
in here you sample 1 sample from that
normal distribution and then you feed
that sample into your decoder again your
decoder outputs an image from that
sample and you compare this with the
reconstruction loss and now you train
the entire process so your train d-did
the encode
and the decoder to produce to reproduce
these images correctly now if you only
do that then you're then the model will
basically regress to a standard auto
encoder why is that well what's pretty
easy for the you can see that estimating
the distribution is harder than
estimating just the latent code at least
for the training data set right so if
you don't pay attention what's going to
what the encoder is going to do is it's
it's going to say well like if I just
make this here my latent code and if I
just make this as small as possible like
zero or like one to the minus ten the
tenth that that's still one ten to the
minus one that's not that small ten to
the minus ten eleven twelve okay
a very small number then that normal
distribution will basically be just
spiky around my around the thing around
my mean and so this here will always be
kind of the same Z so it won't be a
distribution at all it will just be this
Dirac and I'm back to the original auto
encoder which I don't want I want my
probabilistic framework so I can compute
likelihoods and so on there are various
advantages to having a probabilistic
view of the data rather than just a
model that produces it okay and that's
why in a VI e there is not only the
objective or not only this objective the
reconstruction objective but there is a
second objective where we say that we
impose a regularization and the
regularization is that this here is as
close as possible to a standard normal
distribution and I guess you can you can
choose that the prior but in regularly
you say okay this here I don't I don't
want you encoder I don't want you to go
far away from a standard normal
distribution like do what you have to do
to make the loss small but
don't go away too far all right so
that's the kind of balance in the VA II
and as you can imagine if you have a
normal distribution and you sample these
Z vectors here and the reconstruction
loss is always the same so if you input
the same X here a bunch of times you
will get different Z's right you get Z 1
Z 2 Z 3 because it's sampled from this
distribution there's a sampling
procedure right here so if you're
discriminator here is kind of smooth
then it will output different images now
these images will always be compared to
that same input image right so your
training this whole architecture to
always reconstruct that input image from
different images so the there is an
interaction I think I think that's
what's happening I guess I'm not an
expert on on vis but this here usually
is something like the l2 loss so in
terms of how this affects the images if
I have different images that are sort of
the same but sort of different and I
have to make it l2 loss close to this
image right here then one option I have
is to make them kind of blurry so if I
make all of them kind of blurry in the
l2 loss that will give me a lower
penalty so that's I believe that's one
of the explanations I heard at some
point Y VA es produce usually blurry
images and that's been a problem for a
long time that everything is kinda kind
of blurry so here the VA the
hierarchical VA II comes to the rescue
so how they are going to battle this
problem is by doing a hierarchical
variational auto encoder and this is how
it works so you start off this is your
your generator by the way once you've
trained your VA e right once you've
trained it you can simply sample from
your prior from this year because that's
you know close enough to this or you can
I guess learn the prior of your data
distribution and so on and you can just
use the generator
right here the generative part this part
right here is your generator in order to
produce images so you can sample from a
VA II like you could sample from again
ok so here we'll look at a model that
could combat those things on the right
side you can see the model that you
would ultimately sample from so this is
going to be your decoder
okay this generative model right here
and what they do is it's very similar to
if you Nvidia also have this paper about
this this Gann where they are on
different scales like progressive I
think prog again which was the first
that introduced actually this high
quality face data sets I believe at
least so here we're going to do a very
very similar trick so the idea is that
we start out and this is a learned
quantity but you can also view it as
just kind of the zero vector we start
out with our noise we sample our noise
but our noise is going to be it's going
to be let's say it's in the shape of an
image we can do that we can reshape
images right so it's going to just
convey a 16 entry vector and it's going
to be shaped like this okay we sample
noise like this and then we produce an
image of 16 by 16 from it I think they
start with 8 by 8 or something like this
but in conceptually you do that then you
have a neural network this is a residual
neural network produce an image out of
that noise right it Maps the noise to
the image so this is your this is your D
your discriminator part but then you're
not done what you do is you would
actually up scale that image or that can
happen in the neural network I believe
or you are up sampled from the beginning
and you enlarge these things but what
you would do is you would upscale your
neural network and you go higher
and so on so you go higher and higher
and higher in the hierarchy of noises so
this is a hierarchical model
oh yeah down here so they they start
they start from as you can see it
consists of 36 groups in their case of
latent variables starting from 8x8
scaled up to 128 to 128 with two
residual cells per latent variable
groups okay so you continuously scale
and scale and scale up your your your
images and each time you add another
bunch of these noises right here so that
means that in this model you can the
uppermost residual model can sort of get
the course details of the image and
that's going to be blurry because it's a
VI e but it's going to be blurry in that
course scale and then you up sample it
and you let another model add on top of
that the next layer of the next layer of
features you can see this is kind of a
residual connection right here and you
again sample and you let another neural
network up sample ah sorry you know let
another neural network add more features
in a higher resolution so even though
hvae can be blurry in its own scale it
will be upscaled and there there will be
additional details added and that's why
in their samples you will see that
they're not super blurry at all though I
have to say something right here if you
look at these images and you compare
them so later they compare them they
like they're almost look like puppets
right so here you compare it to these
are these our previous methods down
there now you know to say that they're
pretty there you can see they're clearly
kind of worse in that you can leave this
symmetry of the faces aren't really
given also the symmetries here there are
no long-range depen
then seize the hair details are often
missing as compared to like here this is
pretty crisp but if you look at like the
skin of people and just kind of the
image composition in shadows it looks
like these these people are like
cardboard cutouts here they have like
these multiple layers where I mean am I
the only one that that just sees this
this is like a plastic cutout and then
the face is again like a plastic cutout
and the faces are so smooth I mean look
at this these are like too pretty like
you can just look at this for hours as
is so like the the differ it may be it
just seems like this to me but the
difference if you kind of look at this
skin and it almost feels like the bottom
ones are actual real photographs in just
in terms of the faces and the kind of
the color just the smoothness it's just
all look like porcelain this might
actually be an effect of the VA II right
because it's not blurry right as a you
know the the lines and so on but the
this skin texture might just be one one
scale too much here and that's where we
now see the blurriness or it might just
be that I don't I don't know okay I have
no idea at this just this just somehow
whereas was popping out to me as the
main difference like they are much more
crisp and so on and much more beautiful
but also they look like puppets yeah
alright so let's get back to the model
right here because so once we decided
that we want such a hierarchical model
what we need to do is we need to simply
build a VA e for each of these
hierarchies right so the the uppermost
thing here is a regular VA e noise right
we have a noise we sample from it and we
generate this particular scale of image
okay so how do we get that noise we
simply this is this around here is our
this is our encode
this is our decoder we simply have our
encoder this is a series of neural
networks and we get our latent encoding
right so the Z is obtained through the
the kind of v AE encoding method okay
now the interesting part is how do we
get z2 and you might just think well
we'll just go like one layer up here but
z2 as you can see here it depends on z1
during sampling so during inference we
have also have to have that z2 depends
on Z one and that's why we first need to
go to z1 and actually produce a sample
so our method of inferring the latent
codes includes already sampling from
those latent codes right so you sample
and you do the same thing as you would
do in the right in fact these models are
shared and then you can see that z2 now
depends on z1 in this procedure because
you go here and you go here and here so
z2 depends on Z 1 Z 3 in turn would
depend on z2 and z1 and you have a
properly hierarchically factorized model
right here okay so this this is called a
hierarchical VA II it pretty much works
like a VA II except that it is
hierarchical and you need to do you need
to have this bottom-up and this top-down
model in order in your encoder and so
now there are a bunch of questions with
respect to the hierarchical VA if the
problem here is that you have not only
one sampling procedure but you have
sampling procedure upon sampling
procedure upon sampling procedure and
this can get pretty unstable I guess
pretty quickly so the rest of the paper
is going to be how to get this to work
so the main I think one of the main
parts they do in order to get this to
work in order to get this to Train are
residual connections so we know that
residual connections are kind of a sort
of a gradient flow highway in order in
order to to Train very deep networks and
we've already seen this with
the dual networks in CNN's where you
have an input and you have some
computation in form of a neural network
or in this case a sampling procedure
through a distribution and you have an
output and the residual connection would
allow you to skip part of that as you
can see used here in both the encoders
and decoders so in the encoders you have
residual connections and also in the
decoders right here you can see you have
residual connections in fact you always
take that lower scale and you don't
transform it into an upper scale you
actually sample noise and then you add
the lower scale and the upper scale
together so it's really an additive
model in a hierarchical fashion even
okay the the pluses might actually not
be okay the process can also be
combination I guess I guess that that I
might be wrong and they can actually be
combinations in any case they use
residual networks in in in a lot of
cases in their generative and in their
generator and in their encoder you can
see right here there is a residual cell
for the generative model and the
residual cell for the encoder now the
exact method of these residual cell you
can see that they use batch norm then
they use one-by-one convolutions in
order to go to a higher to a higher
channel number before they do the depth
separated 5x5 convolutions so five by
five because you need a larger receptive
field they make that clear they need a
large receptive field however the large
receptive field means many parameters
means their model would be too big and
too much memory so they do the depth
separated convolutions which simply
means that you don't mix the channels
during the convolutions so you go up the
channels and you do a depth separated
convolution and go down the channels
again all of these are kind of hacks to
make it work right then also they have
patched nor
and they swish non-linearity as you can
see here and then here as well in the
encoder
they also say in the text like they
stress the importance we found that
first the batch norm and then the
convolution is better than the other way
around and so on to this there's a lot
of engineering work that went into this
right here
so you see there's batch norm and also
you have to kind of hack the batch norm
because in batch alarm you have these
training parameters and people have
observed that in VA es if you during
inference during sampling if you use the
training way where you only regularize
within the batch it's better than if you
use the running averages so okay they
kind of have to hack that we modify the
momentum parameter of batch room such
that running statistic can catch up
faster with the batch statistics there
is a there's a lot of engineering here
like there's a lot of things that you
have to get right to get something like
this to work apparently and yeah this
the paper the paper just goes on in this
style so you can see they use the swish
activation they use squeeze and
excitation locks which are another form
of residual blocks that were introduced
quite a long time ago but still being
used as you can see and yeah so that's
the architecture so you can see they
have residual cells there residual cells
here reducing the memory requirements
them they say they use two tricks first
of all we they do mixed precision using
a cool new in video library given that
they're from and video they get to try
these things out first and second of all
they also to reduce the memory refuse
batch norm and swish and we store only
one feature map for the backward pass
instead of two and they have to then
recompute this trick is known as
gradient check pointing in Christ
recomputing Bachelor on in the backward
pass I I believe like future deep
learning frameworks should just take
care of that for you instead of you
having to to do this kind of stuff
honestly
so they also need two days here they say
taming the unbounded KL term so the KL
term is what makes the distribution that
the encoder outputs close to that
distribution that you want like that
normal distribution so this is the
regularization term you can see here
it's a KL divergence between Q which is
what your encoder outputs you can see
that's the the latent code for the image
X between that and between your prior
which you say it should be it should be
a like a normal distribution in this
case it should be a hierarchical normal
distribution and they have a special
characterization here where they say
because it's hierarchical right so what
does it mean to have hierarchical normal
distribution so I'm going to have a
hierarchy of normal distributions this
is my top hierarchy and then I'm going
to sample one sample right here right
and then in the next layer I'm going to
have a normal distribution around that
sample right here and I'm going to
sample from that and so on so my
hierarchical normal distribution is
going to be always where the next
distribution in the next layer is
dependent on the distribution in the
higher of the hierarchy and they have a
special parameterization where in order
for the encoder to produce that so the
encoder has to produce a Z of the first
layer and then a Z of the second layer
and so on in order for the encoder to
reproduce that and to be close it must
match this distribution and it must
match this distribution so if it doesn't
match this distribution correctly it
will kind of sample somewhere else a bit
right and then that distribution that
base will already be shifted right here
so it thinks that the distribution to
match is now this normal distribution so
you can see that the base is already
shifted and that's why their encoder
only outputs the Delta
to the as you can see here there it only
outputs the Delta to the prior we define
here we define the Q of the Z in a given
layer as the normal distribution of the
Mui with Mui that's your prior see
that's your prior of that layer plus a
delta mu and also the Sigma is the Sigma
from the prior times a delta sigma that
you output so you're kind of saying
you're not supposed to output the the
actual distribution you're supposed to
output the difference of distribution to
the prior now in layer zero that's the
same thing right because the prior is
going to be zero mean and unit variance
so that's this here this here at lazy
Rho and this here will be one but in all
the upper layers this is going to make
it easier so that's one trick you have
to make this repeated sampling not hurt
you as much the other trick they employ
here is special regular sorry spectral
regularization which is a regularization
where you regularize the top singular
value per layer you can use that you can
compute that with a power iteration
people have been done doing this before
and also you can build in some
normalizing flows which so here if we
sample the different if we sample the
different layers what we're going to do
is we're going to sample all of these
things at once right they're dependent
on the upper layer in the hierarchy but
we'll sample them all at once and that
means they are not sort of connected to
each other now in a if we introduce a
flow will basically make them all
connected to each other and build like a
singular distribution of them but I
don't I don't want to go too much into
this because it doesn't gain that much
they say you can just build that in if
you want okay so these are all the
things that at least they list in the
method section
now there are like a lot more that they
are they have to do but ultimately as
you can see right here on on these on
four of these five data sets they
achieve state of the art in fact okay on
this data set no one else has tried but
at least on the other data sets they are
very very competitive as you can see
right here and they compared this to
first of all to other models and even
other models with and with and without
auto regressive flows and they come
pretty close to these auto regressive
models so an auto regressive model would
be one that generates like one pixel at
a time come conditioned on the other
pixels that this model doesn't do that
this model generates all pixels at once
so it's not all regressive but as you
can see it beats all the other all the
other non order autoregressive models
and it gets pretty close to the best
auto regressive models which are down
here they're still better but the the
gap is kind of shrinking is what they
say cool so that's the main result then
they have ablations where they basically
as I said all of these things kind of
contribute a little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit to building this
bigger and bigger and deeper variational
auto encoder so it's hard to say what
exactly makes this work because all of
it makes it work and I guess they just
kept going until they beat state of the
art or until you know they ran out of
tricks again these are the samples that
we looked at and I do want to spend some
time in the appendix right here because
I think it's pretty pretty interesting
what they do so first of all they show
that their model doesn't remember the
training samples as you can see right
here these are always the nearest name
from the training sample so the model is
fairly you know fairly far away from the
training samples but yeah I mean okay
maybe it's just me but the left they
just look like more kind of more ideal
idealized humans like very smooth humans
like designer babies here they show that
if you use batch norm as you would use
it
I think regularly where you keep these
running stats or you do the yeah The
Bachelor on from training then you get
into this kind of degenerate case if you
sample at lower temperatures so the
temperature that you sample from
describes the width of the Gaussian that
you ultimately want a sample from and if
you do they have this method to readjust
the batch norm statistics which I don't
want to go into here but you can you can
read it up to basically fix that problem
it is a problem that apparently other
people have observed as well and their
method apparently is you know is a is
one that manages to do that okay lastly
there are some more samples right here
and yeah this right here this is
honestly this is one of the I think one
of the most interesting things where
they go and since they have this
hierarchical model right so here is like
z1 it gives rah and so that give gets
you like an image and then there's z2
and that gets you an image and then
there's v3 and so on and you
continuously upscale and hierarchically
add the features here they say what if
what happens if we if we sample z1 once
and then we fix it and when we only
sample the other ones conditioned on z1
and here see where you see top scale
fixed and you can see there is
considerable variation
the image but there is there is not
really a large scale variation okay so
the general face keeps constant but
there are details changing as you can
see so here the hair is kind of going
over the image the color is changing
here there are a lot of changes the
mouth looks slightly different as far as
I can see but I might be hallucinating
here and then if you fix continuously
the top two scales or the top three
scales right here top four scales you
can see that there are more and more
just little details that change more and
more so yes so this is we they are
operating at five scales starting from
8x8 up to 128 to 128 in each row we fix
the samples at a number of top scales
and we sample from the rest of the
hierarchy as we can see the long range
global structure is mostly recorded at
the top of the hierarchy in the 8 by 8
dimensional groups the second scale does
apply at some global model does apply
some global modifications such as
changing eyes hair color skin tone the
shape of the face the bottom groups
capture mostly low-level variations
however the lowest scale can still still
make some subtle long range
modifications for example the hair color
is slightly modified when we are only
sampling from the lowest scale in the
last row this is potentially enabled
because of the larger receptive field in
our depth wise several separable
residual cell yeah I don't the hair
colour changes okay slightly maybe I
don't know my my eyes are too many faces
okay but you know what certainly the
case is that their models exhibit much
better kind of global unity compared to
these other samples where you can pretty
clearly see like the different sides of
the faces have little to do with each
other and so on and this is the benefit
that you get from doing this
hierarchically so you have part of your
model that's responsible for kind of the
global shape of the image and then that
keeps it consistent and then you have
other parts that are responsible for the
details okay so I hope this was
something to you know that interested
you I myself is as I said it's an
engineering paper so there is lots of
things described there's not like one
jumping idea
I guess residual connections are pretty
important and these depth-wise
convolutions save memory and but also
all of the all of the other things that
you have to do to build something like
this are pretty pretty interesting yeah
I I hope you gain something from it and
I'll see you next time